there's no rule that you need to clean  your face for a certain amount of time  30 seconds or 60 seconds or whatever  when you cleanse you need to mix the  cleanser with the oil on your face so  I'll rinse off so the molecules in your  cleanser and on your skin have to  rearrange from this to this to this  these Emulsion droplets can get rinsed  off and you end up with Clean Skin if  you're an efficient rubber or if you  have an efficient tool then you won't  have to cleanse for as long to get  everything to emulsify and be able to  get rinsed off but if you're not as  efficient you might find that you'll  have to cleanse for a bit longer to get  the same thorough clean